this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is supported by patreon
patrons actually also got last week's
episode with uh some audio issues I
chose not to publish it publicly just
because of those audio issues but if you
do want to check it out you can watch it
as part of the Charizard tier on patreon
they also got a slightly longer version
of this episode and get access to all of
my podcasts in general but most
importantly are really the reason that
I'm able to make these ad-free very
independent podcasts continue being made
so if you like the show I want to show
us some support check us out on
patreon.com
but we're here uh you've you've been
super busy I have been yeah getting
getting a
getting a stray Gods out the door just
five trillion Loose Ends
um to what's your release date if you've
put it out though August 10 it is upon
us oh [__] okay so you are
you are those last few annoying bugs
then okay oh that that yeah that part
theoretically uh should hopefully be
kind of uh passed
um you know console especially yeah
again yeah the cert process
it's for me the it's the runway of
interviews and soundtrack album stuff
um by the time this airs we will have
announced that I'm releasing four
separate soundtrack albums to try to
cast as wide a net as possible around
the branching Choice wow um so it's just
like the sheer amount of mixing and
mastering and and and editing and stuff
in terms of each album follow a
narrative line so do you have like one
album where it's like you chose this
kind of path and it's like following
through or is it more of a mix and match
no no it it's so because the game has
um
uh three kind of uh color-coded traits
that you were choosing yeah so I thought
well because I for the longest time I
thought I don't know if maybe there
should be no album because
it's like just embrace the idea that you
have to just play it to get it and you
were like I need more feedback exactly
well because because then it was like
well I don't wanna my biggest fear was
any album no matter how much you try to
put caveats on it will kind of canonize
whatever choices that album must
comprise and it's totally unfeasible to
just release like
everything because it's it's like six
hours of material and but they add up in
thousands of permutations so it's like
it's not even really a practical thing
to do it would be this unwieldy totally
unenjoyable kind of archive which
wouldn't no one would
bother with that and so I was like after
a lot of thought I came to the
conclusion
uh three of the albums can be each of
the three colors if you just only ever
hit that the whole game
so it's kind of like drawing a triangle
around the the real game because no one
will play like that
yeah like one narrative line basically
that staying in one lane basically for
them yeah even then I had to make some
subjective choices because even under
that umbrella there's a lot of potential
variation like for example there's
optional romance character subplots and
things like in BioWare fashion so I had
to kind of make some some subjective
choices that seem to just Naturally Fit
but but the bottom line is that it
becomes this odd point of reference
because
for example the red Choice the kind of
antagonistic aggressive way to go I
doubt there's more than a fraction of a
percent of players you know assuming who
are just gonna who are just gonna like
at every single of the thousands of
Crossroads go yep that's that one again
the least popular choice in every single
choice in this game well and bear in
mind
I really want to play fiction as if
they're good yeah well in this this was
this what I liked about this one this is
total David Gator
um uh credit is that it's not actually
Paragon Renegade like Mass Effect it's
just it's just like confrontational
versus intellectual versus empathetic so
it really is three different styles and
they're mostly styles of reaction versus
proactive you know someone says
something to you you can basically be
like
[__] off or you can go
I think I understand why they did that
and I'm not good then I'll climb they're
just nice
it's it's yeah it's it is it is it is
yeah exactly it's it's it's
outsmarting them trying to understand
them or fight fire fire kind of you
could think of it in the crude so it's
like all right a red album a blue album
a green album that represent each of
those three traits just a hundred
percent committed through and then the
fourth album is
uh looking and seeing which uh uh like
bits and pieces are are totally omitted
by by across those other three and
saying let me try to come up with a
sample kind of seemingly arbitrary but
not play through that kind of threads
and avoids as much overlap as possible
with the other three albums so that
between four
I cover the most amount of possible
material
um in terms of hours Austin would you
say this is like the most you've worked
on a single game
like uh deliverable material you mean no
just in times of the amount of hours you
spent working on um it might be because
it was it was five years
three of which were pretty full-on
um yeah I remember you talking about it
when we were working on John Wick I feel
like you were in the very earliest kind
of conversations back then weren't you
Liam and I met at GDC and immediately
were like let's do this in 2018.
um but it really ramped up pretty
aggressively towards the end of 2019
um
and then
um and then like 20 20
2021 was really high-speed songwriting
2022 was Our Endless thousands of
recording sessions with the cast members
they was like 90 sessions
um
was that largely individual I never
asked you that or did you do it like in
the same room yeah
protocol literally we couldn't even try
it I couldn't even be in the room in the
booth uh we had to resume yeah for a
beautiful moment I should go about yeah
of course it was right at the tail end I
don't actually know where those rules
stand now because we were right at a
point where
it was starting to feel like those rules
were kind of antiquated because because
you know we were just so thoroughly over
the hump of it you know especially
because we were still doing testing and
and they there were still vaccine
requirements and stuff so it wasn't like
they just people were left on offices at
the same time so like but yeah like
musician like I would record with a with
a hundred piece Orchestra but then not
be allowed to be in the studio with a
single engineer and a single actor and
so it was kind of like we were in a
slightly mismatched place but it was
fine it actually worked out
uh really conveniently because
um I was able to have the song open on
my computer
um which was really helpful to be able
to have my setup and then have them on
zoom on one screen and like all the
sheet music and all the other stuff on
the other and that actually turned out
to be really really helpful that I would
have had to sacrifice uh so it served us
well because this the sessions as many
as we booked they were always high
pressure because there's just 50 billion
things to get through
um how do you feel now that it's almost
out
um I I'm excited I you know every we
released a single uh this week uh uh
through Game Informer it'll it'll come
out commercially tomorrow like as of
tomorrow I.E it'll be yesterday as of
when this is published uh and um I think
assuming plus or minus
um and um
that uh seem people seem to like that
which is really nice uh that technically
could have heard it already because it
was it was part of our thing at the El
Rey um but it's like a nice polished up
version
um of the opening song that Laura and
Ashley sing and so every little kind of
inkling we've also done two demos on
Steam like part of the summer games Fest
and the Ludo nericon those people who
actually could play it yeah and like the
to me the test was when YouTube started
to get populated with people going you
know here's the Pan song every version
and it'd be an hour-long video and I'd
be like that's not every version
um and uh but but like just to see that
people even wanted to try to find
everything
is very much our hope you know that like
if it's good enough that you would not
just play through and go okay that was
cool but actually go I wonder how
different this really gets under certain
conditions
um that's the hope you know it's it it
so we'll see I you know I I feel like
I kind of feel similar
um to uh when we were sitting in that
window after being essentially done but
still under like review embargo and not
out yet with journey where I was going
I have no idea if other people will like
this but I do think we've more or less
made the thing we set out to make so
it's like if you like it
that makes us thrilled if you don't it's
probably just a difference of taste and
opinion uh and that's all fair
um but I'm not looking at it Winston
going
it's a I just really hope people give it
a shot because it's a super compromised
version of what we set out to make you
know like sometimes that is the case and
you just hope that people give it up
games right yeah 100 you just pray that
it it'll get worse with this I've
definitely yeah we've definitely ship
games like that yeah 100 yeah so we'll
see you know you're proud of it it's a
you know I'm I when I see people's
playthroughs and stuff I I invariably
I'm as proud as as my capped sort of
capable capability to be proud is
because I just immediately go
boy it would be a like I found I found
something in one of the edits I won't
say where it was but there was one of
the things that I was like this is kind
of
a mistake that I realized somehow
survived every step of the process in
terms of
some of the songwriting Pathways I I
found a thing that I I'd realized it's
possible that I didn't think would be
possible and I don't want it to be
possible uh like a thing a player could
do wow
and I was like damn it and it was one of
those that like I I lost a considerable
amount of sort of uh I burned
considerable amount of energy pre like
fretting over that uh but it's one of
those where it's a rare instance of of
going
I don't know if this is actually a good
thing but I don't think there's really
another any other game you can quite
compare it to and that's a rare thing to
actually be able to kind of feel
reasonably confident in saying you know
it's it the other the other things you
would compare it to are heavily hedged
caveat filled comparisons because you
know it's just it's just weird and
unique and that's that's fun I feel like
my perspective and I think I said this
to you before is that stray Gods I guess
can we just give the synopsis for anyone
who has no idea what this game is by any
chance how do you how do you describe it
Austin it is a the full title is stray
Gods the role-playing musical uh to to
to try and really
make clear it is not an RPG but it is a
game that is almost like
uh an extension of the idea of improv
theater in in a sense kind of where it
is a thoroughly narrative uh
uh Adventure almost quasi-point-click
Adventure in a sense
uh where you are solving a murder
mystery of sorts where your main
character of Grace played by Laura has
been accused of murder you have a week
to prove your innocence lest the the
Greek gods of old uh
uh execute you uh as the prime suspect
sort of guilty tell proven innocent
style and
um and your the side effect of the Muse
uh from whom you got your powers is that
you essentially can create musical
numbers they are diegetic in World
Musical numbers that the characters are
very aware of uh and and from which the
truth is gleaned and so you are able to
role play a variety of sort of
personality traits in order to navigate
the different personality types of the
Greek gods that you are engaging with
there's a there's a message
hopefully yeah I think so it well
numbers aspect is really the part that
sort of makes people go huh yeah and I
feel like uh I think critics are gonna
love it and I feel like people are going
to be extremely impressed by this game
in a way that isn't super common in that
what you've done is so unique and so
seemingly difficult to execute but it's
also like it seems like the kind of
thing where people who don't like
musicals or don't like this kind of
choice based game which is totally a
thing you know some people might might
not like the genre I think will
regardless be impressed
by what the game has actually done
well you know we'll we'll see it it's it
is it was definitely a village a massive
collaboration from a lot of folks um I
certainly had an enormous group that I
was kind of leading just under the
umbrella of the music never mind the art
team and you know animation visual
effects David you know David went from
leading a writer's room uh or a writing
team on a Dragon Age game you know scope
you know year multiple Dragon Age games
Knights of the Old Republic that kind of
thing to being the writer meaning every
last fragment of text in that entire
game had to come from him so in a way he
went from AAA game
for which he had to do less work and
um because it's a it's a crazy amount of
writing uh you know for a game that but
did you contribute to songwriting as
well
oh yeah no I mean I I wrote I wrote the
overwhelming majority of the music in
the game and that which I don't sorry I
mean songwriting is in uh
lyricsist oh no that I claim no uh
credit on the so the way it worked was
I'm not a Lyricist as much as I as much
as I wish I could I'm I I sit at this
intersection of very picky about lyrics
and and therefore I I kind of hold them
to a higher standard than they seem to
want to come out of me as interesting so
so I much prefer to collaborate with
folks and the the guys from Australia
tripod I have worked with a bunch of
times we wrote songs together for
Assassin's Creed and a bunch of other
stuff and and so that was essentially
one of the first calls that I made was
to call to bring them in and say can you
can you do this with me and and very
immediately rather than just me throwing
music over the fence and they staple
lyrics to it which was kind of what I
thought would be the case because I was
so embedded with the team that I thought
I don't know how it's going to be able
to work any other way they're they're
just not privy to as much as I am
they're just not even able I think to
commit that much amount of time to
really be in Long calls Breaking Down
The Narrative of the scenes and all that
kind of stuff so I just figured it would
be a kind of one way I'd shoot music
their way they'd add lyrics but they're
a bunch of nerdy Gamers and they took to
it so immediately that we almost became
like a band of our own and very quickly
it was just we were writing the songs in
every sense top to bottom together as it
yeah and then and then and then the
scope expanded so much that we had to
split into sort of three strike teams
where the three members of tripods John
Scott and Gates and I each basically I
paired up with each of them individually
so Scott and I would be working on a
song Gates gonna be working on a song
Yan and I'd be working on a song so I
was the kind of common ingredient across
all three to make sure that everything
was
uh was clicking but then we were very
much writing the songs
um together and then I would uh sort of
take that back to the team and and
represent it to the team and and then we
brought on a fourth songwriter named
montane also from Australia
um where I continued that that same
pattern so I went back
actually everybody they were bringing
such great ideas that I went back to
um
to Liam and I said I don't want this to
create the impression that that every
you know every last little note in the
whole thing I sort of was be all end all
with me it was a group effort they would
change things I would send the music
they would change it sometimes they
would just show up with an idea and I'd
we'd play with it I'd go oh that's
really cool what if we did this with it
and and and and so I said I wanted to
just say songs uh co-written by all of
us and that my role was
in addition to composing and of course I
had to write a whole score as well in
between the songs but I was like in it
separate from that I said I'm acting in
a music director role
um where you know I I had to produce
everything and direct the cast and all
that stuff but there's definitely
material in there where
we kind of came up with it together I I
wouldn't even really know
how to identify who wrote what by the
end because it's like well I remember
this idea came over and then yeah and
then I said well what if we placed it
over here and then I could kind of cut
this part of it off and we could add
this thing that's kind of complicated
with song credits right like I know
there are some game studios that now
just do credits and they just do
alphabetical they don't even say who did
what which I kind of like uh that game
company did that on journey I remember
yeah it just listed and it would be like
the founder of the company next to an
assistant because they're alphabetic and
nobody really knows
anything which either upsides and
downsides too obviously but I yeah
there's some downsides but yeah I mean
especially for people who are like
trying to be credited for specific
things for their input oh it sucks for
the careers of people who are not like
above the line yeah and it's easier when
you're part of a small team and you're
interviewing somewhere for you to be
like well I wasn't credited but here's
part of the portfolio of what I worked
on or whatever but I understand that
credits for music can already be really
complicated is there like a um like a
sag adjacent kind of Union who is
specific to crediting with this kind of
thing or is it different because it's a
video game there's there's no um sort of
Union angle on it uh for complicated uh
judicial reasons uh where composers are
not unionized or even legally allowed to
unionize in the U.S
um but there are there is a Musicians
Union that covers all the non-composing
aspects but but but no game is really
ever done under music it's pretty much
just for film and TV and live music
stuff gotcha
um but um but uh there are conventions
for sure and there are organizations
like the Society of composers and
lyricists and the game audio Network
Guild and whatnot that do seminars and
things at GDC and there's definitely and
also between composer agents there tends
to be a little bit of a convention and
um so well so for the four albums what
do your credits look like
I put on the on the album cover that I'm
the music director and that the songs
were co-written uh by by effectively the
five of us the tripod the three of them
montane and myself
um and then I brought in a friend it
like on band campus where I'm able to
get super granular like on the bandcamp
page when it eventually goes live you'll
see like a 50 000 line 50 like it just
gets really hyper specific because every
single musician you know we recorded
orchestral aspects in Australia and in
Nashville
um you know there's a bunch of soloists
my friend yoris uh hookstadter is a as a
he played all the drums on it but he's
also this amazing kind of pop music
songwriter and producer and because
that's not my normal space
um I brought him in as kind of a
sounding board and then eventually just
said I'm just gonna credit you as a
co-producer on the entire musical
everything for this because there would
be so many times where I would be mixing
something and you'd spend a whole day
just on the drums and it'd go you know
I'm not convinced that the kick sounds
the way it would and I'd send it to him
and he'd go oh here's what I think we
could do and he would come up with
suggestions and and we just spent you
know a year and a half basically joined
at the hip
um where you know the amount of work
that she contributed was so massive that
I was like uh you know I need you to
have a very high level credit on this
thing to feel like I'm even approaching
honoring how much it's benefited from
your
your insights and and thoughts and and
suggestions there's so many times where
I would go I'm not quite sure like okay
here's a perfect example
um
this is a really cool one there's a
scene where
um
the there's a showdown wait this is one
of the bits we did at the lra there's a
showdown between grace and Persephone
Mary Elizabeth McGlynn's character and
and Laura where they're in like a
nightclub and one of the paths lets you
potentially rally the people the
onlookers into like a choir in the hopes
that it would sort of overwhelm
Persephone and make her back off like
her whole audience of people sympathetic
to her if they switch sides to you
she'll kind of you know relent that's
sort of the premise of one of the paths
you could take
and so a thousand years ago they did a
fig campaign for this game and there was
like a hundred people that you know sort
of was like we will find a way for you
to be like background singers in this
somewhere we hadn't written any of the
music we had no idea what that would
mean but we were always on the hunt
while riding it to find those spots so I
said you know what if there's a the like
a chunk of those singers we use in this
scene as the crowd that sings with Grace
um and so it went to our big people and
said you know okay here are all the
sections and and you know from their
angle it was probably super disorienting
because it would be like here's a
fragment of a few seconds here a few
seconds there and I would send them just
like these totally isolated bits where
they had no idea what was what but of
course in the game it's like a whole
choir coming to life and it's super cool
and
so I got all these vocals well you know
as you can imagine from crowdfunding a
kind of thing half of these are people
recording the laptop or an iPhone and
stuff and you polish it up you make it
sound decent but it never really felt
like a crowd all right acquires not
recorded
okay I guess usually they're recorded as
a choir literally choiring together what
you're saying you did is record them
individually and then put them together
as a choir yeah yeah I mean just by
virtue of it being the crowd-funded sort
of sound different
it's just random people off the internet
basically doing this yeah it's it's a
random the very respected wonderful
people yeah
oh wait wait it was your best it was one
of them it was one of the Fig uh that's
so cool that's such a good idea we we
did a hundred Slots of if you want to
sing backup vocals you know as a
credited member of like the sort of like
that's so cool
it was really it was really fun and some
of them were really into it some of them
were really really good um and then some
were just kind of like hobbyist singers
who were good enough uh you know
especially for a choir anyone terrible
did you have to cut anybody
uh there were a couple folks where yeah
I I helped him out a little uh there
were definitely some some that benefited
from technology a little bit but so
tuning but yeah but the nice thing is
when you're in mass and also it's not
meant to come across like
like yeah like something you would hear
at Albert Hall it's supposed to sing
almost like when you hear people singing
in Anthem at a soccer match kind of
thing where there you can very clearly
tell what they're singing but you're not
holding it to the same bar that was kind
of what we were picturing because the
idea she's rallying a crowd of random
people at a club that's the scene so it
would have felt funny if they were
immaculately perfect obviously in an
Ideal World you get a choir together and
you'd sing it in a studio properly but
we had this Kickstarter or this fig
thing and so that was where we were
going to be sourcing at least some of
these vocals I I gathered other vocals
other ways but this was the main like
the meat of it
um and there's history people if you
know like 10 plus years ago Eric
Whitaker kind of uh cracked open the
seal on this kind of a concept by
um uh creating this virtual choir if you
look up his piece look so room k
um he he just put the call out online
and it was like a couple hundred people
formed this pretty amazing choir uh and
it went very viral you ended up giving a
Ted Talk on it this was all ages ago
he's since then done it a bunch of times
where each time it it grew in popularity
to the point that there's like tens of
thousands of singers now on the ones
that he does and um it's very very cool
he has people record their webcams so
you end up with this Sea of Faces like a
literal virtual choir all positioned
like they would be and they spend ages
mixing it and the honestly the biggest
challenge with it is that there tends to
be kind of room tone from people's
computer fans and their ACS and when 100
people all have that there's quite a lot
of noise so you have to spend a lot of
time eq'ing all that sound yeah because
it adds up so much so this was a perfect
example where
um you know you do all that you sculpt
it and then you're listening to it and
you go
it doesn't it still doesn't read the way
it's supposed to read so I go to yours
and I go
I'm open to suggestions and why didn't
it read the way it wasn't supposed to
like what were you objecting to it
sounds like 20 people over dubbing
together they're they're you can feel
how close they are to the mic like if
I'm uh doing this you can hear the
difference then if I'm here sure can I
hated that yeah I don't die I don't
blame you
uh of course the listeners won't really
get too much of a difference because
they're here that's right I always
forget you have two separate mics this
one's just for you
um so uh you know close mic'd recordings
are really hard to sell as being a crowd
in a space
um and so it just didn't read like a
crowd in a space and I tried a bunch of
different things and you can try adding
Reverb and all that but doesn't really
quite and yours had this brilliant idea
where there's this there's this great
plug-in called morph which is basically
you load in two two different sound
sources and it will algorithmically
intermingle them almost like if you're
pick if you have a jar and you're
pouring in two different colored sand
into it and they become one amalgam that
you can't really pull them apart anymore
it's not just layering two things it's
actually sort of mathematically
combining them
um and it's a really slick location
no no we we combined this we took a we
took the sound of the choir and made a
single composite of everybody singing
and then using this plug-in mixed it
with literally just white noise
and this is the kind of thing that I
wouldn't necessarily have thought of
this but it was like you're canceling
out you're kind of yeah well it's one of
those things we have to make it
imperfect to make it believable the
White Noise actually made it
sounded it added room tone in a sense
and so what it made it sound like is
that they were in a big giant almost
gymnasium kind of environment is is the
effect that that has that's the kind of
thing where I don't think I would have
thought of that one uh at least under
the time constraints that I had I
certainly would have but yours goes what
if we try that so that was like this is
this is why I'm crediting you as a
co-producer is [__] like this where
where I just need a solution I'm sitting
here mixing the music and I'm not happy
with it and he goes try this and it was
like freaking stroke you literally don't
know what the solution is so how are you
supposed to do it like I know in um like
Gran Turismo and Forza they add
imperfections to the cause because with
no imperfections they look less
realistic so I'm saying it's kind of a
similar thing is you are like it's too
perfect because it's
13 look so [__] filthy yeah because
it was CG because the real thing was too
clean it doesn't look real wow so you
always have to do that I don't think I
ever heard that
video game Graphics is largely about
adding noise and dirt to things that's
what realism is it's just noise just
just anything that looks imperfect and
this sounds like same thing done sound
yeah it was it was I I I I didn't mean
to monopolize I I thought it was just
gonna be a passing comment about why
I've been so hard to pin down no I mean
it's consistently interesting and like I
know people are excited about I was
going to ask you guys if you've seen
Oppenheimer or Bobby was what I was
gonna go in with but I don't mind
talking about Street gods for an episode
it's cool with me I've been a month I've
seen you Austin I know sorry about that
uh that's okay I was I was shocked that
not only both were as successful as they
were that both outperformed all the
product predictions going into the
weekend as well very good weekend for
Cinema
um yeah I saw an interesting to
statistic that that um as a point of
reference this was now the the fourth
highest
um
opening weekend ever but interestingly
the the three above it were Avengers it
was like force awakens uh in game and
infinity War yeah which shows that just
how colossal in a pre-pandemic world
theater is really still work that each
those films on their own were why the
box office was and it's the combined
power of Barbie and Oppenheimer that
Rivals because I feel like with Bobby
and Oppenheimer you get every audience
there's nobody who's missing out except
maybe little boys but like everybody
else is there
um anything that's funny I thought of it
through that lens but you're right it's
also a weird one though because
I was like whoa it's so good for these
things that aren't IP Bobby's IP
Oppenheimer is a known man slash event
It's Kind it's kind of it you could kind
of argue that the Oppenheimer IP is
Nolan
um who's like who's developed such a
kind of I'd see anything he makes brand
too yeah like he's so reliable there's
an interesting thing where biopics are
basically ownerless IP that makes sense
obviously the kind of the families like
that's that there is a very noticeable
uptick in biopics in this era of kind of
everything's based on IP if you think of
most of the things that aren't
immediately it's like oh no but that was
the story of Mark Zuckerberg's life or
that was like it's always based on a
book or a story yeah what was your
thought on the two of them Alana you
watch both right
so which is better and more culturally
worthy what's who won what do you think
they're so different uh yeah I haven't
put my review of Barbie up yet I'll
probably try and do that today now that
I have a working PC
um
they're both very very different I liked
Oppenheimer more than I liked Barbie
which uh is not necessarily the popular
tech people are really split on it I
just had some issues with Bobby uh I had
some issues Oppenheimer too but I think
less
um
I think up and I met some issues
but I assume from history like yeah it's
a really interesting movie it's edited
like it's Montage it's so [__] fast
and it's non-linear because Nolan
clearly likes that kind of Storytelling
and there's just like one big thing
pages in order yeah but I don't mind
that he does things out of order uh but
there's one big thing that I very much
would have put at the end
um that isn't at the end so the last
half hour of the movie is a little bit
like
I've heard every critic dance around the
exact same thing you'll say like that's
the thing that and obviously I can guess
or what that big thing might be in the
movie but like it's pretty big it seems
like everyone's kind of dancing around
that as an interesting kind of
when you get to the end it feels a
little confusing and then you're like
what why is this still happening and I
get why it is if I actually sit down and
think about it but it's uh I'd be very
curious to hear Nolan answer why he made
that choice when it seems like an
obvious flaw my issues with Bobby
um maybe that I went in with too high
expectations and that um even the
friends I have who've liked it I was
just talking to two of them yesterday
and I know you start asking questions
and they're like oh yeah what
um I think it should have went harder
into being a silly fun comedy and I
think the messages that it tries to send
it kind of fails at uh
and people are so split on it like like
I've seen like it's a movie that's
teaching women to hate men which I think
is an absurd take but like even that you
could make a case for and against
um
there's a lot I can't talk about any of
it without spoiling the plot but they're
like it's telling an interesting alone
that you've
you're saying that you don't think that
that's the point of that film but it's
not you can see
that yeah because
the movie itself is confused uh and has
several messages that I think it doesn't
really nail it sort of feels like again
I think if they had gone Full comedy the
funny parts are very funny well
Farrell's hilarious Michael's hilarious
Ryan Gosling is absolutely incredible
but then like if it's a feminist movie
why is Margaret Robbie crying for two
hours
you know I've heard I haven't heard that
that's funny she cries like the whole
movie
um she doesn't not what I would have
expected in a like the the I
yeah that I've heard that I've heard
that the marketing portrays it quite
different from what it is which is fat
which is fascinating like people
everyone I've talked to has been
surprised by what the movie actually was
like I've avoided spoilers so I'm
looking forward to seeing it myself but
like yeah it does seem to be one that
isn't matching what people's
expectations are going Oppenheimer
everyone seems like yeah it's exactly
what you think it is pretty much yeah
yeah the only thing that got me was the
editing so fast I didn't expect that it
honestly is like a montage it's like a
single scene doesn't last more than 30
seconds at first I was like oh my God
like it's so his films are normally very
stately aren't they they're very kind of
loudly worthy like they take their time
they're very they set up yeah not always
but I mean certainly like they think
Dunkirk you know I haven't seen tenet um
but to me Dunkirk was one scene that the
the strength of that film was that it
felt like it was like Mad Max Mad Max
also to me felt like it was effectively
a single moment yeah that sustained for
an hour and a half I love it I love that
like a couple of weeks ago that movie
gets better and better I was so worried
you were gonna say it didn't hold up and
I was like no no I genuinely like it's
one of those ones that the more times
you watch it because obviously there's
quite a few like twists and turns in the
prestige but like it's it those twists
when you re-watch it a couple of times
it's not that like
you don't feel smug watching it you just
keep appreciating it more layers you
didn't see last time it's brilliant so
much going on I don't know that there's
any Nolan film with the possible
exception of tenet which was a
bafflingly confused film from by so much
better the second time when you're not
trying to work out what the [__] is
going on well they have quotes they said
they didn't know what was going on Nolan
and Robert Pattinson both were like I
didn't know what was happening either
like it's it's the first time you watch
that film your brain is trying to like
work out the narrative and you can't the
second to I the second time I watched it
I genuinely loved it because I knew
enough about what was going on that I
could kind of just enjoy the
performances and well that's like I
watched primer twice in a row
primary still ain't [__] on this I've
watched that filming three or four times
I still don't get pregnant I managed to
I get it for the first like 10 minutes
and then it falls off for me I just
don't get the dude who shows up and
vomits that one is still there's YouTube
explanations of it but it's still yeah I
did also watch an hour-long YouTube uh
explanation of primary but yeah I
haven't seen tenant I think Rises
actually is maybe the only Nolan film
that I do think gets worse every time I
watch it
um which is I've already watched that
unfortunately it's just funny I thought
I always thought that
I've seen that film twice and I thought
that I liked it the first time and I
remember going the problem was he
recalibrated our sense of expectation of
what this kind of movie could be so
outrageously with the Dark Knight yeah
that no movie will feel
satisfying and it has a few and they
lost Heath Ledger who was originally a
big part of the script
um and chose not to recalls which I
think was the right call there that was
smart that was the right choice and it
has a it has a few things that are you
know maybe Tad silly but I always
thought that movie was I just said it's
just it's just it's it's crime is that
it's an above average but otherwise
fundamentally normal superhero film I
didn't really feel like people are like
oh that movie sucked and I got I don't
think it sucked yeah I just stolen I
just didn't feel like he won it to me
and I don't know if this is true I
assume it's not it didn't feel like he
wanted to be there he didn't want to
make it begins and Dark Knight they feel
like passion projects I think all of his
films feel like passion projects that's
why I enjoy them is it feels like
someone who is making exactly what I
want to make and that film feels is that
he did not want to make it yeah it was
like a movie you want to make yeah and I
think I think I agree it's no I don't
think it's a bad movie uh it's just
maybe
one of Nolan's worst but like that's
still it's a pretty good catalog
that's the one I've not seen I've not
seen insomnia since it came out that's
the one following which no one's seen is
genuinely
going back oh I okay I would have put
following below Rises that would be my
least favorite of his movies but maybe
really but I haven't seen it it might
just be that I'm giving him props
because like it was his first thing you
know it might be I might be being I
might be being friendly though
I was just telling Angela about insomnia
the other day she hadn't seen it and
I've only seen it once but I remember
thinking it was really solid I remember
when I watched it back 15 years ago or
whatever that was more period where
people realize Robin Williams was could
do creepy yeah excellent there's quite a
few movies from the movies like one hour
photos and insomnia came out right on
top of each other if I remember
correctly and I remember going good
parent yeah this guy one hour photo is
such a deliciously creepy I haven't even
like what's that what is that Robin
Williams I imagine it's the premise of
it Williams yeah he plays it he plays a
guy who works it's it's one of those all
beautifully dated films in its premise
too he plays a guy at like a Kmart or
whatever that that develops your film
when you bring it in and um and he
developed it's just this he's this very
creepy guy that develops kind of like a
parasocial relationship with the people
whose photos he's developing and it kind
of goes from there it's a thriller
um and but it's just there's so many
moments where it's just him smiling and
looking at somebody and you're like it's
just it's just great I I remember
thinking it was so good there's a
certain kind of comedian who just really
pulls off creepy and he he nailed that
and I've always had I mean good things
about him like I'm saying good bloke but
like he could play Creepy so well
um because I think probably a lot of
people overdo it
I think you got it there's got to be a
little bit of subtlety and creepy
I think comedians as well are such
consumer performers that I imagine it's
very easy to put or not easy for them
but natural for them to kind of just go
into that kind of uncanny valley I very
much feel like stand-up comedy is just
another form of acting you're still for
sure 100 don't turn off they have to
improvise they have to keep going with
it like they're I don't know like
there's there's like I think of like Joe
Pasquale who was a British comedian when
I was a kid who always spoken like a
squeaky voice like all this it was every
time he was talking he was talking about
that on television and I remember as a
kid being like asking my dad like why is
his voice like that and my dad happened
to explain to me his voice isn't like
that that's just how he talks on tell it
because this guy never dropped the ACT
it's it's it was always that was always
his persona it's we have seen interviews
with him like I guess it's similar to um
oh what's his name Iago from Aladdin the
the American comedian from Aladdin
the the parrot in Aladdin
I can't I can't believe I don't have it
off the top of my head but again like a
silly voiced comedian but like that's
definitely not how that guy probably
talks in his private life but that kind
of commitment to it that's why I'm
saying Alana is it's you're right it's
acting but it's actually Gilbert Godfrey
to make your entire Gilbert Godfrey you
have to keep that performance going all
the time so I can imagine I I remember
it's actually I think it might be I
think it might be a Joss Whedon quote
which is a shame because Joshua yeah but
I remember reading an interview with him
when I was just when I was starting to
like have to cast actors for things
which was basically if you can get a
comedian they're a good actor just don't
think so you'll get your hit rate with
comedians for acting and that's why a
lot of my games are comedians in most of
the roles because comedians are reliable
reliables is definitely a good actor
um
in the office like he had I don't think
he had any prior acting experience and
he's he'd been in a couple of like
comedy sketch shows and stuff in the UK
but no not like his performance as
insufferable as that character is is
amazing like it's precisely because of
his performance that the character is so
inside but this show was exactly he's
achieving that yes no the level of
discomfort that that show inspires is
truly like strategy I've heard a lot of
Americans hate the UK office because uh
surreal foreign
I think like bothersome like a lot of
Americans don't like the discomfort in
it or something
I think I was reading an article about
it I don't doubt that it's too
uncomfortable American office is more
conventional as well isn't it but that's
a bit more sitcom
also
um Yeah well yeah exactly the uplifting
is a good word I was searching for
Michael Scott is more redeemable than
than uh David Brent Michael Scott has
all the cringe but he's so lovable that
you Americans want to laugh with
characters British people like to laugh
at characters like British comedy is
mean and British humor is mean like I've
I've got like what I've got several
American friends I've had to learn not
to talk to the way I would talk to
British friends just because British
people just are constantly right just so
you're not a natural and I've had a
married I've had a marriage like I've
had American friends it I've had
American friends genuinely like come up
to me like privately and be like do you
not like me are you like I'm like no I'm
I'm I'm being cruel to you because I
love you like that's that's what that is
people who really loves me that's the
Mike Bethel story is that it's it's
certainly the British humor story alone
they backed me up here that is also the
Australian approach right it's 100 True
your real friends are the people who
and it's a weird adjustment for that's I
I have a hard time uh I I I fully buy
that on a culture level but you're such
a softy Mike that I think you might be
the gentlest version of that British
archetype of any Brit because it just
doesn't like the way I talk to my Brave
friends yeah I hate you that's what it
is no but like genuinely no no I'm
saying you you you you you pull your
punches all the time like you understand
yeah you have no malice on your
I but it I it would be overstating it to
call it code switching but I 100 talk
differently to Americans than I do to
British people like if you if like the
way I talk to you I would like I I
literally had a call with a British
friend before this and I was just like
openly like mocking him for like every
choice he'd made that day like that's
British people of different I feel like
I've learned something pretty I need to
see the real authentic sort of yeah
because you think I was an [__]
there is a difference
like I'm gonna develop an entire like
Mrs Doubtfire Persona I'm gonna I'm
gonna enter I'm gonna reintroduce myself
to you we're back you don't know who I
am
all right yeah yeah the way I talk to my
mom I remember an American friend
overheard and was like you talk to your
mother that way and like yeah because
it's funny
yeah like it's all Cola names because
it's funny whereas American Mothers
would take it very seriously be very
upset about it or whatever
yeah slipped a couple of times and like
sent a text to like an American friend
in like a British town and they've then
just like blanked me for a couple of
days like genuinely like I [__] up
like I've upset people well for the
record I think I would be pretty
receptive to it because I've always
loved British humor and I've I've
understood why fellow Americans are put
off by it but to me the yeah they just
they just sort of unfathomable
pain of of awkward silences where things
are just left utterly unresolved I've
always found absolutely hilarious and
I've never been afraid to instill that
into social moments I actually don't
think I'm pretty mean to you Austin I
would say I'm probably I'm pretty sure
both of you no that means I like you
that's how it works like I would say
that I'm
pretty normal to you where there are a
lot of American friends that you have to
be overly polite to where you can't make
fun of them because they'll actually get
upset
like you hate yourself saying some of
these things and you're like it's
reasonable that they would think I was
being a dick in this situation totally I
get it yeah I get it I made a joke once
on a panel where
somebody joined and I that it was just
like a I didn't mean anything but I said
something that was like you think this
guy's important
and he was very upset uh afterwards and
I was like I would the only way I ever
would have said that is if I did think
you were important and I was making a
reference to that but I like really
really offended him and I was like I'm
so sorry again I wouldn't have said it
if I didn't think it uh just a joke but
I was like got it okay can't do that I
understood it's when people hear it as
well like I've I've had it before I'm
gonna I'm gonna obfuscate a lot of this
so it's not traceable but like I've had
it where like I've been in a meeting
with like American partners and British
Partners like on a work basis and then
after the meeting they've been like do
you do you two British guys like [__]
hate like you're just constantly
undermining each other than me it's like
oh no we go way back we've known each
other a decade like that's fine that's
yeah it's it's just a it's a different
thing it is maybe my resilience to that
um maybe the American uh uh sort of
natural predisposition to be off put by
that is counter acted by the fact that I
grew up around Fair bits of Jewish
Gallows humor which has there's a lot I
think there's a lot of crossover yeah
yeah it has a fair bit of like there's
nothing that is off the table uh I mean
it's like you think of Schindler's List
where there's the people in the in the
[__] camps telling jokes uh and it's
like a very classic snapshot of Jewish
and I've never you know my family's
Jewish I've never particularly
identified as Jewish but but you grow up
around you naturally like when you meet
people who were in The Holocaust telling
jokes about it at that point you go
literally everything is fair I I I don't
think anything if if that person there's
no line to cross there's no line left to
cross like I feel like that person just
blessed everything that exists uh by you
know like with their stamp of sort and
and that's not to say there aren't
things that horribly bad taste but it's
like at least in your own life pretty
much
I'll laugh at anything that I would do
or you know and and it's pretty hard to
get under my skin especially if I know
you're coming from a good place very big
difference in the jokes that you make to
your friends and the jokes you make on
social media too I think like you can
learn if you know the audience yeah I
don't make jokes on social media that's
that's the that's the trick that's the
thing like where you go a lot too I've
seen stand up it's not worth it I've
kind of just boatloads of stand up and
and they there's also just something
about when you like I can appreciate
when comedians get incredibly irritated
with the audience will turn on them
because it's like you came here for this
yeah like it's one thing to not laugh
it's another to then go you know to
cross over into trying to shut somebody
down now it's a totally different thing
on social media where you haven't
cultivated the audience around you the
way you bought tickets to a to a show
that's a different environment
completely now it's just the wide open
world and you're theoretically everyone
on the planet could read it and so it's
also context clues right like I've found
the only times I've ever gone in trouble
on Twitter I don't get into if I make a
joke on Twitter that's going to get me
in trouble I don't get in trouble for
the first 12 hours because the only
people reading in the first 12 hours are
people who know you follow me or it's
really circles are aware of me it's
always three days later from summer camp
that I've never in the quote Yeah it's
in the quote tweets it's always it's
always that one step removed because
because yeah context clues right you
when your mate makes a joke you have the
full context of who that person is and
you can kind of Judge them accordingly
um but like yeah it's always that kind
of much later which is why yeah I
wouldn't want to be a stand-up comic
because that's all you're doing is
talking to strangers
um no but The Bravery
Angela has really got it you've done I
have yeah you've done on stage yeah yeah
um it was really fun and in that context
still very easy because it was uh uh at
a rooster teeth event and thus was a
bunch of Rooster Teeth fans so like they
have contact crowd yeah and they really
want us to have a good time they're
rooting for you inherently yeah yeah um
but I also like I found it very fun like
it was when was this I've never seen you
do that uh it is it's I think it's on
kind of Funny's YouTube channel maybe um
they work out I think that's where I saw
it was like they did like a little dot
because yeah yeah same thing right and
it was five minutes each so it was just
a five minute thing and I just used a
bunch of jokes that I had made in other
places and made a story out of it really
um yeah it was really fun I I would do
it again uh but I would be so interested
to do it to a crowd who doesn't know who
I am because there's also a bunch of
biases that like if you do stand up to
an audience who doesn't know you
being a girl with blonde hair is going
to inform something and then like what
you say and how you sound out of that
you know it's anything you know like you
have glasses and curly hair they're
gonna make some sort of both of you kind
of they're gonna make some sort of
assumption based on that uh so I think
it the minute you walk out the context
is super different I don't know how it
would go
uh I I did you did you write uh like I
assume this was material you I wrote it
backstage wrote and like you had thought
about this wasn't off the cuff no I
again I read it backstage maybe an hour
before we went up because I knew what I
was gonna do again it was just based on
like previous bits as most stand-up is I
think that I just kind of put together
um it just worked out the joins exactly
so kind of yeah put the constructive
yeah and I had it on a note but I I and
I was comfortable doing that because
most people that night did that but I
probably didn't need to do that but it
also gave me a nice out if I was
uncomfortable and I could look at my
phone which uh most stand-up comics also
aren't allowed to do
um in any case
we have to end the show yeah I gotta run
me too uh we did it though sorry it's a
little short everybody but at least we
made an episode look at us go
uh I'm on a piece I'm a video game right
and that's my ability to video game
director and that's awesome entry he is
uh now a music director audio director
that means something else
take the title
and that
oh yeah uh we'll hopefully see you next
week I don't know
uh
not me you two should see each other my
mom yeah anyway we'll talk about this
all right bye
[Music]